foreign
[Music]
already know about how administrators
can use IAM policies to lock down who
has access to specific resources within
their organizational control however it
is also important for administrators to
consider the resources and data their
users might access that sit in an
unauthorized Google Cloud organization
introducing organization restrictions
that helps administrators to restrict
users access to only resources in
authorized Google Cloud organizations
why is this feature important well in
fact there are many Avenues of attack
and opportunities for data exfiltration
which must be considered when evaluating
and strengthening your security posture
take for instance this potential
phishing attempt where a bad actor can
create a rogue organization and Grant
all of your company's employees access
to this Rogue organization this bad
actor is hoping one of your company
employees mistakes this organization
with your company's organization and
mistakenly uploads company sensitive
data there in another attack scenario a
malicious Insider could deploy their own
Rogue Google Cloud organization grant
their corporate identity access to this
Rogue organization via IAM policy and
exfiltrate corporate data to this
destination effectively security
administrators cannot prevent employee
identities from accessing resources
outside of their corporate organization
in Google Cloud
fortunately you can now use organization
restrictions to help mitigate these
risks by setting guard rails on what
resources principles in your
organization are allowed to interact
with
regardless of where they are granted
access via IAM policies
organization restrictions your employees
must connect to Google Cloud through
managed devices such as company laptops
which are configured to send all of
their internet traffic through an egress
proxy managed by your security
administrators
this egress proxy adds an organization
restrictions header to any Google
cloud-bound requests originating from
these managed devices this proxy
configuration allows security
administrators to specify a list of
authorized Google Cloud organizations
and prevents users from accessing any
Google Cloud resources in non-authorized
organizations
commonly organization restriction
headers can be set up to satisfy a
variety of use cases restrict employee
access to resources only in your Google
Cloud organizations and disallow access
to resources in other organizations
allow your employees to access a vendor
Google Cloud organization in addition to
your Google Cloud organization
or
Corp employs access to partner
Consulting organizations to get started
with this feature visit our
documentation we've Linked In the
description there you can learn more
about egress proxy prerequisite
requirements additional configuration
options and Google cloud services which
support organization restrictions
enforcement
need to test this before you have your
egress proxy set up check out our test
guide which we also linked in the
description thanks for watching and
learning how to better protect your
company from data exfiltration with
organization restrictions
[Music]